hi everyone in this video we'll be
talking about mixed inhibition as the
name suggests it looks like it is a
mixture of two different kind of
inhibition paradigm and in this video
we'll look at that so under normal
conditions with no enzyme interacts with
substrate from seconds I'm substrate
transient complex which ultimately give
rise to enzyme and product and the
enzyme remains unchanged and we get the
product right but under a condition of
mixed inhibition the enzyme substrate
forms enzyme substrate complex but the
inhibitor can either bind to the enzyme
substrate complex or it might bind to
the enzyme competing with the sub
substrate as well and then as a net
result the product formation does not
take place so we can see here the
inhibitor can operate in two reaching
one is like uncompetitive inhibitor
instead of binding to the enzyme
directly it binds to the enzyme
substrate complex and second regime it
can also operate like a competitive
inhibitor so that's why it is known as
mixed in a patient let's try to
understand the mixed inhibition and try
to derive the michaelis-menten equation
under these circumstances so here is the
equation now ki and ki - are the rate
constants for these two possibilities of
inhibitor binding now first we try to
write the expression for ki and ki -
with the laws of equilibrium we can
derive these expressions right from
there we'll now write it in a different
format like AI is e into inhibitor
concentration divided by the rate
constant ki same for here we would write
the expression like this and in a moment
it should be clear why we're writing and
we would be using this formulation later
now we know that under these
circumstances there are four species
first tens I'm alone second
with inhibitor only third the enzyme
substrate complex
and fourth enzyme in the format of
enzyme substrate and inhibitor complex
so the total enzyme is like combination
of all of these now from here we can
start deriving our equation and now we
know what is the concentration of e aí
because we have already write this
written this notation and also we know
what is the concentration of ESI means
after that we can take we can further
formulate it and do a little bit math
and we would arrive into this situation
now in order to shorten this equation we
can assume that 1 by I plus K 1 is alpha
and 1 by I plus 1 by i / ki - is alpha -
and as a result we come to a situation
like this now if we multiply both the
sides with k2 we know that k2 ETS means
p 0 and K 2 ET means V Max and then
rearranging the thing gives us the
equation like this now this is the
equation for mixed inhibition now this
is how the kinetic data look like in
normal situation of Michaelis Menten
equation which is like this well the
slope is km by V Max and this equation
is a straight line plotted in 1 by V vs.
1 by s scale now and the intercept is 1
by V Max now in this situation of mixed
inhibition both the slope and the
intercept has changed you can clearly
see the slope has increased that's why
the line becomes steeper and the
intercept is also different and the
intercept has increased suggesting the
v-max has decreased right and the
intercept become alpha dashed by V Max
so clearly we can understand this kind
of inhibition reduce the v-max to a
factor of alpha -
and with the increase of value of alpha
- the line becomes steeper and steeper
and the vision becomes stronger and
stronger now there could be two type of
decreasing game either the game could be
greater than the game a parent or the
game might be lesser and both is
possible for this kind of inhibition now
if the game is greater than the apparent
came that means the it more closely
mimics the competitive binding if the
game is like red a lesser than the came
a parent is lesser than the game then
what happens is it more mimics the
uncompetitive binding now one of the
special case of mixed inhibition is
non-competitive inhibition where our
both equation both reaction constants ki
and ki - are equal that means alpha and
alpha - star equal so here is the
Michaelis Menten equation how it looks
like in a V versus s plot now clearly
there would be a decrease in v-max but
the game remains the same in this
condition and here is how the
lineweaver-burk plot look like under
non-competitive inhibition
now remember non-competitive inhibition
is one of the special case of mixed
inhibition in this situation these lines
would meet at a point minus 1 by K in
the x-axis and the intercept would be
more because the v-max has decreased to
a degree of v-max by alpha and that is
how the non-competitive inhibition looks
like in a lot of language Weaver Burk
let us take an example of
non-competitive innovation cyanide can
be a non-competitive inhibitor of
cytochrome C oxidase and there could be
that it that's why it could be
detrimental for us
and that was pretty much discussion
about the non-competitive in the mixed
inhibition and one of the special case
of mixing mixed inhibition which is non
competitive inhibition I hope you
enjoyed this video and this video was
informative enough so if you like this
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you